bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
greetings of peace thank you for tuning
in to the Deen show and we are excited
that you're with us again for another
exciting topic in the Deen show studio
chef holiday scene and for those of you
that are tuning in for the first time or
you got your family member or friend and
you're with us today we're going to be
explaining to you how because many times
when we try to bring up these very
important topics you know what many of
us we just don't got time for it the
economy's bad you're about to lose your
house on foreclosure your kid your child
your girl just got pregnant and your
son's on drugs I'm doping the world just
upside down and you want to just talk to
me about religion now I don't got time
to that I got major issues well this way
of life that's from the crater that
heavens and earth solves all your
problems so we're going to be doing some
problem solving showing you that this
way of life is a way of life that when
you implement it it is something that
brings not only peace and contentment to
one's life but solves all the problems
that are out there we'll be right back
here with Shakeology as seen on the Dean
show
Salam alaikum peace be with you
him some what happens a lawyer but Qatar
how are you sheikh ali love thankful
groom thank you thank you for joining us
again here at the d show studio glad to
be here brother and we you know it's
just something that for us we're
convinced through research I know myself
I personally went through a lot of
struggles in life a lot of problems and
Islam solved all the problems it wasn't
something that was accepted by blind
faith did a lot of research to the
scientific analytical approach and the
more I studied it along with many
millions millions millions of people
they were convinced that this was a way
of life from the creator of the heavens
and earth through deep research through
researching all the other world
religions so now for those people who
are having problems you know they're
about to foreclose on their house that
can't economies upside down so many
problems and you know what don't bring
me this this religious stuff I you know
then how is this going to change my life
how is it gonna solve my problems you
know what do you got to say about this
[ __ ] well you know I think that that's a
very simplistic approach and it may seem
over simplistic to most people but it's
not you know at this at the source of
all problems there's some fundamental
issues and from a purely religious point
of view
unless religion can be manifested
through the solving of problems why
should anybody
want to join our religion or even talk
to us about religion as I was mentioned
just a some time ago even though America
is a very religious country according to
most statistics eighty-one percent of
Americans believe in God go to church
once a month or whatever the case might
be which is a phenomenal a place to be
where it's no problem about believing in
God it's something everybody but what
kind of implementation do we have so but
today people are running away from the
religion running away from it yeah not
running away from the religion itself
but running away from the principles yes
no Muslim nobody want to talk about
religion today as you said unless the
religion has a solution now because it's
solution you know if your muffler drops
off in the middle of the street what are
you looking for you looking for a place
somebody can put that back up there so
you do something with that sound if your
car stops you're looking for a mechanic
sir - solve the solution and unless
Muslims the eight million Muslims living
in North America unless we become a
solution oriented so so what if we
recognize the same problems that
everybody else recognizes if our
religion doesn't somewhat lead to the
solving of those problems why should
somebody won't have time I want to talk
to us about religion so I think that
what we need to do is take a sit down
for a moment and set aside doctrine for
a moment set aside culture for a moment
set aside all the nostalgia about the
most powerful religion 1.5 billion
people bla bla bla and ask ourselves are
we solving problems and if we are
solving problems then we should be like
that dentist okay that everybody wants
to come to because he's giving them a
good smile that doctor that everybody
wants to come to because this guy got
some procedures or whatever makes them
feel better you know that psychiatrists
or psychologists who solving problems in
homes and marriages you know and
restoring people's dignity and sanity
if we're not like that then why should
people listen to us
I mean how did Toyota coming to America
and take over the automotive industry
wasn't because they had chopsticks you
know I'm saying in good Chinese food or
whatever God or Japanese food
no it was competition is producing the
best product and service and giving
people that when they buy a car the best
warranty that's how they did it and
Americans eat it up and now we're Torah
Nissan or whatever ethics that is once
you buy one you're not gonna you're not
gonna ride in something else well why
wouldn't people listen to Muslims if
they knew that we had a way to restore
our economic integrity and I mean we got
something simple in Islam to do that
stay away from River stay away from
compounding interest stay away from that
whole idea of something for nothing
don't buy credit cards you're being
ripped off you're being set up and don't
Americans see that right now so if
Muslims were to say hey we're 8 million
and we got our own Bank you know and our
bankers words I mean 38 billion and
we're willing to buy back the homes of
of 10,000 Americans if they qualify
what's the qualification okay let us
manage your debt number one cut up your
credit cards number two do not engage in
any more you serious transactions and
take a course in Islam 101 so at least
you understand the principles and if you
do that we give you back your home so
how many Americans then would be looking
for our company so your problem solving
now the problem solving according to
Islam yes so Islam is saying that there
is no compounded interest interest is
totally forbidden yeah but leave the
word forbidden alone yeah you know just
leave that word forbidden just give the
people back their home give them back
their homes okay and didn't tell them
let us manage your debt cut up your
credit cards and sign a document that
says that you will not get into this
situation again I think people like this
yeah there was a because they're like
I'm getting my home back uh-huh yeah so
we got their attention yeah so let's
take another problem you know today we
have more young people in jail we have
more young people in
jail that certain countries have in
their workforce so can we take those
kids out of jail and provide them with a
lifestyle an option okay that will
reform their lives yes we can okay so we
tell young people listen just roll with
us you got a job role with us gonna get
you through school roll with us we're
gonna set you up and teach you how to do
business on your own you had to work for
nobody else you're going to wait for a
job just roll with us but the thing is
first reform yourself where you are
reforming yourself means be disciplined
be decent be good you know be respectful
you don't be balanced you know prepare
yourself for success dress in a certain
way speak in a certain way okay and
while you're doing all this we're gonna
give you guys $300 a month
yung Simmie just while you're doing this
it cost so how many young people okay
would want to take that and then we can
go to the courts and say listen we got
alternatives to incarceration program
you know for one out of every three kids
you're gonna put in jail and it's gonna
cost thirty eight thousand dollars a
year to take care of them in jail for
the taxpayers money give them to us and
when we show you what we can do with
that young person give us two out of
three until we solve a problem for the
taxpayer we solve a problem for those
parents we solve a problem for those
young people people don't even care if
we're Muslims if we're solving that kind
of a problem so our issue is that where
you know we're prone towards doctrine
we're arguing about doctrine who's right
who's wrong from from an ideological
point of view from a school of thought
point of view I mean that's some old
baggage we need to solve problems when
we start solving problems where people
are hungry people are confused you know
people are frustrated people are
committing suicide solve those problems
and then America is gonna start looking
at us for the solutions when they look
at it from the solutions they're gonna
hear our ideals and some of them are
going to inevitably embrace Islam
problem solving not just talk but action
yes so Islam takes care of all these
issues drugs alcohol abuse we got
problems there big time how do we solve
these problems well you know
Islam has solve those problems
throughout its history I mean you know I
don't like to say to people oh you know
we don't we're not allowed to eat pork
we're not allowed to drink alcohol oh
you know we're not allowed to dance with
girls we're not allowed to go to parties
that's like like just like no no no no
no no who wants to join a religion
you know it seems like everything is no
no we say that you know we don't drink
because it's obvious what drinking
alcohol does it's not so obvious when
you manufacture alcohol you know people
who manufacture our alcohol they just
get rich and rich people who manufacture
cigarettes they just get richer and
richer so why wouldn't I want to help
manufacture alcohol and cigarettes but
look at what alcohol and cigarettes have
done to our country look what it's done
all over the world okay then you can see
why God said don't take toxins into your
body and don't drink alcohol now if we
were to promote the whole idea of a
sober society a sobriety okay a society
of sobriety that sounds good right yes a
society of sobriety so what would we do
if we convinced 10 percent of America's
not to drink what would we do if we
convinced 10 percent of Americans not to
use drugs what would we do in a market
we would teach people moral abstinence
sexual abstinence okay you see a decline
in STDs and so many other kinds of
problems so we already have this in our
religion or our system of life why don't
we promote it but promote it in a
non-religious way and Allah knows best
we're gonna take a break shake and we're
right back with more we share holiday
are seen here on the Dean show whatever
Allah commands
this land has tolerance and mercy and
compassion to know that Allah you know
will forgive you as long as you do what
you need to do as long as you turn back
to him
Islam is a system of mercy and
compassion and it is for the best
benefit of all of the people that
surround it Muslim and non-muslim
back here on the Dean show and today
we're showing that this way of life that
was lived by all the messages of God
it's not an organized religion by man or
men or a company is organized by the one
who created this whole universe and
everything in it and when you implement
it the right way all your problems will
be solved is this correct that's correct
tell us now there was a show on MTV I
got to see it at the end elucha Center
with our brothers down in Texas and they
were showing us how they tried to reach
out to a lot of the youth and I have
these get-togethers and they use some of
the things that are out there for
instance there's a program on MTV called
cross the line so what they showed was
there was teens there were teens that
were 14 15 16 17 even some young young
adults and now they asked the question
that how many of you have attempted or
tried to commit suicide about 60 70
percent they cross the line doesn't
she'll cross the line a big problem now
why are teens these young adults primont
that this is the prime of their life
it's a big problem for parents and those
teens trying to take their life thinking
about it even how does it slob
solve this problem yeah you know we
could say that suicide is forbidden in
Islam yeah we approach it from that
point on yeah this is Haram yeah you
know but that's just a doctrinal
statement people just don't wake up one
morning and say I'm gonna commit suicide
today no it's a combination of
frustration low self-esteem other kinds
of complications that bring a person to
that point where they don't see any way
out and they don't see any value to
themselves and they don't see any value
to their lives or to the world so they
get to a point where they just kind of
think to themselves hey man I think it's
better for me not to be here this is my
way out so they don't see themselves
crossing the line that of course it's a
stage of insanity for a person to take
their life and not to see anything else
but the point is they haven't been given
any value at that point what Islam does
is gives a human being value when a
human being has value of themselves
value of the world they see they see a
light at the end of the tunnel they see
an objective - what they're doing
they're not gonna commit suicide why
because they're striving to live and get
the best out of life so I think what we
need to do as Muslims is not going to
this thing about this Haram
you know it's forbidden no we should
talk to people and you'll find out
through evaluation what brought them to
that point and give them to something
okay you know a child if they're brought
to the edge of a cliff a seven-year-old
child a three-year-old child take them
to the edge of a cliff and they look
down what do they do they're gonna run
back they pull back yeah because they
have value it's an intrinsic value it's
a knee-jerk value it's something that's
part of the filter of the human being
when you got a person that goes to that
edge and just jumps off what have they
done dissonance they went into something
they called dissonant rejection so now
it means that that normal value that
comes up it's not Danny Moe why not jump
we need to give them this value and so
by talking to human beings about the
value of life talking to human beings
about the value of themselves talking to
beings about how they can change the
world
talk to the human beings about the tools
they have been given talking to human
beings not from a religious standpoint
of view but from a value base okay so we
can change things if we change the way
we deliver it you know we keep saying
religion to people you know used to
think about a new what's your religion
you know you think but Islam Islam is a
great religion the person is not saying
you hey man I'm not about in a religion
man I'm trying to make some money I'm
trying to get married trying to be
successful ain't even got no time for
religion but I don't think about that
later on but all the things that they're
trying to get to and do cause for value
and discipline so if you said to them
listen along the way towards success try
to pick up some values and tools that
help you stay on point and discipline
they might listen so I think this is the
approach that we need to do and if we do
that whether it's young people are old
people or people
different situations Islam works it
smells good it tastes good it feels good
it looks good and today anything that's
good is good and the Quran said how does
that one accent a little accent is there
any other reward for good other than
good
the answer is Bella definitely I heard a
young man once say that religion he
didn't like using the word religion
because it was like something you put on
Sunday real tight suit or something so
can this can this yeah can this religion
could we is Islam a system a complete
way of lying
is this something that you do just you
know on the weekends Sunday comes Friday
comes you do it once a week but what
we're talking about is this something
that is implemented 24/7 yeah as long as
Islam is micro Islam is macro Islam is
you Islam is the world Islam is
universal is Lomb is us Islam as
everything is integrated it's powerful
it all fits it all makes sense and if
you if you're good Muslim you're going
to be successful you can only succeeds
like Vince Lombardi say there's no
option other than winning if you're a
Muslim so when we are able to take our
faith system and implant it where people
can see it smell it taste it then people
are going to select the stand under our
tree people are going to pick the fruit
from our tree people are going to use
our goods and services and they're gonna
like it and invariably somebody's gonna
find out hey
in fact wait a minute I should be a
Muslim and therefore I become a a
protracted beneficiary of this year not
just like a consumer but I'm part of the
company what if someone says you know
what religion altogether is something
that it creates more problems more havoc
in a land look at all the wars that are
out there because of it I just rather
I'm more scientific I rather stay away
from religion I'm a good person
yeah I don't hurt nobody what do you
guys say well you know scientific you
know when input process is that if you
heard this argument of course I have you
know scientific is like you know see
touch taste feel you know all the
sensory whatever the case might be but
what about thinking see thinking sighs a
guy touch a thought
let me see a thought but you are a
thinking person and you make the right
decision to make the wrong decisions if
you don't have the capacity the ethical
moral capacity to make the right
decision you only can continue making
wrong ones I don't care how rich you are
you know we can just name people who
made wrong decisions based upon their
moral or ethical capacity and this what
Islam gives to us the ability to think
that's what my human being is different
from animals we are able to think and
the Quran came for thinking people not
just people you know some who just
following us I mean just rules and
doctrines critical thinking this is what
Islam gave to us and so the person who
thinks critically adds value to their
lives add value to the lives of others
and add value to life and as value to
the world a farmer he's not just a guy
following doctrine he's adding value and
that's why I think he gets a higher crop
or lesser crop and we need to talk to
people about value and about life and
about success and then if we at the end
of it when people see that I'm
successful you know they see my family
and they see the outcome and they see
you know this guy unlike being around
this guy but I don't know why it's
because the residual of my beliefs
inevitably he's gonna become an ally
well he's gonna enable to become what ya
amazingamazing we're gonna take a break
and we'll be back with more here on the
Dean shell death and the day of judgment
the mercy of Allah these are the things
that finally made me realize there is no
time to delay anymore
I wanted to take my Shahada right there
the essence of spirituality is to become
more sincere tell us opinions on the
fund to protect itself it is very very
scary but it brings you back to reality
there is a life which is everlasting
together we make a conscious decision of
which a group of people do you want to
be off the people in heaven or the
people help back on the Deen show
problem-solving showing how the way of
life from the creator of the heavens and
earth it needs to be a system that /
solves the problems doesn't add to it
but now today there's many
misconceptions that people say why am I
going to be a Muslim it seems like Islam
or Muslims are just adding to the
problems they're making the problems all
the mischief and the land terrorism
things blowing up what am I going to
become a Muslim and then be a suicide
bomber I'm going to end up blowing up a
pizzeria why would I want to be a Muslim
if this is what Islam all over the media
is associated with yeah this is I think
that's very fair a question a very fair
approach and we shouldn't be reactionary
in answering that we should be
responsive and I say to people person
says to me well who wants to be a Muslim
to date I mean you know my parents not
gonna like me if I become a Muslim
everybody's gonna turn against me I mean
you know Muslims are perceived as this
in that I said well I would agree with
you that the way that Islam is perceived
I wouldn't want to be a part of that but
perception is only perception okay but
if I were to tell you you know that a
seven of the major deadliest social
crippling diseases in this world today
Muslims don't have that I mean a good
Muslim doesn't have that kind of a
disease because because of our values
generally we stay away from those kind
of diseases you talk like you know like
sexually transmitted diseases this comes
from promiscuity okay yes
you know there are you know smoking
cigarettes and you know like Muslim
generally Muslims we don't do that now
that we smoke and we don't sell
cigarettes you see you know the
composition but the compounded debt I
mean we only own and buy what we can
afford we don't buy credit cars
this whole thing about the dream getting
something for nothing and you know just
going out and spending above our means
we don't do that okay the second thing
is that this whole thing of depression a
Muslim our favorite statement is
alhamdulillah when somebody dies in the
line or in night Labor's you we're able
to absorb that trauma in a minute why
because our values allow us to do that
you said something Arabic can you
translate those in early life or in that
later resume from from Allah become he's
the owner of everything and to Allah we
returned because he's the owner of
everything you know we say alhamdulillah
all praise due to a God for everything
our prophet used to say still Ali was to
him whenever somebody asked him how he
felt even though he was in pain was
money asked why I felt that he was sick
when somebody asked him how he felt and
he was hungry he always say
alhamdulillah praise be to Almighty God
so because of that his demeanor is
always up he has dependence upon God
secondly person depends upon God he's
not going to young could get frustrated
want to kill himself because he don't
own the life he understands that so as
Muslims we are successful people we are
people that have prominence we're people
that plan
we're people to have discipline and so I
would say that if a person took a good
look at Islam not a good look at Muslims
but a good look at Islam they're gonna
be able you know it's like they got the
book if you got the book you get the
principles and you follow the book and
you follow the principles you don't have
to be subject to the people who have the
book but they don't follow it or the
people who talk to principals but they
don't they don't act upon it so this is
what we have in Islam and I think that
every American should take a course in
Islam 101 you know I call it Islam 101
for everyone why because if Islam is a
faith system that gives the human being
integrity and balance and discipline and
focus and gives them more respect for
themselves respect for their parents our
gives them a greater loyalty and a sense
of integrity about their country and
about the world and gives them a new
world view I think that if a course in
Islam one on one might open me up to
that but I want to take a course like
yes because that's called empowerment
you know people are buying little small
books with a hundred pages and reading
it on the train or a plane to do what to
become empowered so if somebody said to
me just a little while ago why don't we
take you know 40 sayings of the Prophet
Muhammad SAW Sam and don't say the
Prophet SAW said that just put it in a
little small book and put it inside the
Doubleday or somebody said bookstore
with Barnes and Noble and see people
will take it up to change their lives
this is what we can do and in a certain
amount of time we would have overcome
this whole issue of Islam being
dehumanized and demonize why because we
have shown people tangible value now we
believe in Islam that every person is
born in original goodness born to do
good to live good but it's all it's
built on a foundation before we come to
an end can you just talk about what is
the main foundation that this way of
life is built on this way of life is
built upon the principle of doing good
this way of life is built upon the
present the the position of reciprocity
not just having good but doing good you
know it's like the Golden Rule do unto
others as you would have them to do unto
you Islam is built upon that kind of a
principle Islam is also built upon the
principle that human beings are
beneficiaries we are not owners human
beings you see our creation we're not
creators so we are dependent but not
upon each other we're dependent upon a
higher value and so Islam is built upon
this whole idea that human beings have
been endowed by their creator and as
such we've been endowed now we've become
responsible if you're given something
you're responsible to give something
back so because of this profound
principle that Islam is built upon we
have the wherewithal to be able to give
and not worry about it coming back to us
it's got to come back to us we have this
idea that telling the truth is not
because if I don't tell the truth I'm
gonna be found guilty or complications
because when you tell the truth it's
therapeutic its self-cleansing when you
do good unto our human beings the profs
awesome he said well I see no in allaha
yuhibbu Marceline this means in Arabic
so do good unto others verily Allah he
loves those who do good so this the
whole principle of Islam if we were to
understand that everyone in their right
mind would want to be a beneficiary of
that value now we're about to come to
again just a couple more points actually
one more tell us now everything sounds
good and we know that this way of life
it it produces good when you implement
it you do it you live good you feel good
but for some people say you know what
that's what my religion teaches my
religion of Hinduism of Christianity
it's all the same they all teach good so
this is way of life when we start to do
it the cross core now is are there weird
things associated with the two so all
the religions might teach to they teach
good but then you're rolling around with
rats they teach some good and they don't
and then and then you're bound down to a
statue it teach good and then you're
doing some crazy rituals that you know
what the average person his innate
nature rejects this it doesn't fit it
doesn't make sense is there something
weird in the background when we present
Islam that people need to be fearful of
a GI Joe we're gonna pull it down you
got a worship this man over here Eddie I
think I like this kind of like
simplified yeah you know in the world
today countries are measured by products
and services yeah GMP is that what they
call it so you can talk all about your
religion but I say let us all bring our
religion into a forum bring it all
together bring it into a forum and just
and put it out there because when you
put your product out there it can be
examined as these are these are other
products yes we got the best product we
get the best service that's what we say
others say they had best product and
best service ok present your product in
service to humanity and let us see see
Americans five out of eight Americans
I'm told now prefer to buy a Japanese
car
they outwardly does that means that they
don't have loyalty no no it means they
want the best product most reliable so
that's what it comes down to I think
that if we were given the opportunity to
show the products and the services of
Islam
okay these are these are other products
and services or other people's religion
bringing them all into the forum is what
would what would prove that and that's
what we need the opportunity to do we
need the opportunity and we should
welcome the opportunity to sit down with
Christians and Hindus and Jewish people
and Buddhist people and and anybody who
claims to have a religion and because
the proof of religion is just like the
proof of a restaurant what's the proof
it's in the tasting proofs in the
pudding it's in the pudding yeah so so
we should welcome the opportunity to
discuss Islam in the open forum of the
world and for people to ask us so what
have you done lately you know not what
Islam has done but what are we doing now
what's our plan for the future and if we
come into that forum and we don't have
the answers something is wrong with us
nothing wrong with Islam and that's what
we need to prepare ourselves to do and I
think when we do that the world and our
society and our fellow Americans they're
going to be able to see the beauty and
the power of Islam thank you very much
for a time thank you very much me always
always always nice to be on the Deen
show and always we look forward to thank
you so much for to having you again may
God Almighty the Creator a lot of award
you thank you so much thank you for sin
tight to another episode of the Deen
show you can visit us here every week
same time same channel to learn more
about this way of life you can also give
us a call anytime 1 800 662 Islam and we
hope to see you again next time until
then peace be unto you